[Music]
welcome to winners on a Wednesday my
name is Samuel Leeds and I am absolutely
delighted to have the Mandel family on
the show and I'm gonna be asking rad
some questions about his property
success but also how he's managed to
bring his family on board and which I
just think is absolutely incredible
two of the four family members of now
and our full-time in property
financially free so rad it's an absolute
pleasure to have you on the show
pleasure to be here so why don't you
start by I mean you start when did you
spot the property journey I think it was
about six months ago crash course in
London and and that there were four of
you that all kind of said we're gonna do
this type to grab this opportunity and
out of the four of you how you doing
we're doing really well we haven't kind
of gone out there and burnt it where
we're taking our time we're getting all
the education yeah through your program
Academy is Rick who start one mile did
my eldest started off Kerry she wanted
to go into property rigdon didn't really
care but he got an e-book message from
Samuel Leeds and there was he booked a
course at the London and then he took me
and my wife Jackie with us and with then
and that's why we all started because
the thing is when you started you I know
you is the sort of leader and visionary
of the property business within the
family you wanted to get your kids and
your family you want to get them all on
board but you also despite having some
money to invest you told me Samuel you
say it's possible to do it without using
losing lots of money so I'm going to
start by using strategies like rent
around their packaging and in once we've
got some confidence in your teaching you
said to me then we'll start doing some
some serious big deals absolutely I
remember your words very well at the
first meeting you said study first for
the six months three four to six months
get all the train and get all the
education that's exactly what we did and
we're at a point now where anytime the
big door will open we're already looking
at development plots we're already
looking at residential commercial to
residential and we're thinking of moving
forward from renter ants into
bigger deals love pearl because the
thing is when you're risk averse like
you were to be fair you want to I always
recommend start just with the Train and
invest in yourself get some small deals
your first deals always the hardest deal
see them really coming in see it working
and then stop moving on to bigger and
bigger stuff so what you achieved then
in the last six months as a family since
she's died well as a family we've got
ourselves set up as a limited company we
wanted to include the whole family
because we're a very solid family and we
if one was going to share success we all
share the success and we've all wanted
to be part of that yeah so we set about
our company and everybody has a role to
play
Ricky is the brand of the face my oldest
daughter Kyra is an actuary so she's the
figures and she does a mathematics my
wife Jackie is the admin the attention
to detail on your bank details on your
Aviva was all this whole thing and I
networking helped to search for
properties and meet people so and my
other daughter because of in between her
work she spends all the time sort of
evaluating the prices of houses in areas
that we've looked at the rental in those
areas whether it's viable not viable etc
that's fantastic so what strategies have
you been doing so far well to get
ourselves a bit of experience we started
on the rental rent service accommodation
and we managed to manage to source to
two flats in the centre Milton Keynes
and they're doing very well well sort of
back average occupancy is round about
the 70 to 73 percent so that's giving us
a good return from both of those so how
much cash flow are you making on a good
month we can make up to 1/8 from those
that's grabbed up each one so you're
making about what about on an average
month between the two of them you're
probably looking at around about maybe
one one just over 1,000 plus are you
making a good two to three thousand
pounds a month and then also you've been
doing deal packaging yeah Ricky we we
again invested a little bit in Ricky for
deal sourcing
with Alastair and he's done very well
he's because he has these I think you
recommended one of those away days spent
the whole day yeah so he's been to Stoke
all day he's been to Doncaster and we're
again he's planning something for next
week on a Wednesday and he started
making money doing that he's passed over
I think it's two or three deals he's
waiting to hear from them whether
they've got to go through or not it's
not like sort of a couple of weeks ago
that he managed to do that
crying so we're waiting on that he's
also setting himself up as well as a
deal sorcerer so we got him compliant
and hopefully once he's got through the
training program he'll then be able to
get his list on and move on fantastic so
have you learned a lot so far absolutely
I think he has taught us a lot is we're
more confident we know how to approach
people and how to negotiate whereas
before we probably wouldn't have done we
were gone head first
more than likely we were probably
invested in the wrong thing and got
burnt yeah but now we've been more
cautious careful and we do all the due
diligence before we actually go ahead
and put an offer in having said that you
know we put offers in they don't always
get accepted there is a case of do we
want it bad enough to go back or shall
we just move on because is and you've
also mentioned that in your training if
one doesn't work this thousands others
that you could get so we move on we
don't actually Huggle with people about
we work out mass out and kiri says
that's the bottom line that's all you
can offer and if she says that then we
all go with that and if they don't
accept it it out or if they want us
we've been yeah we've accepted their
offers and then a week later they've
said oh we want 20 grand more so we've
said now that's our offer you know take
it early I mean I've got to know you and
your family pretty well in particular
Ricky who have become very close with
you must be really proud of your family
absolutely proud of all of them and
we've used Ricky he's the Brandis the
face and that's how it's done of the
family are they all support him in that
the nobody's got eyes Ricky doing that
weren't I doing it no it's all support
for him because as a family we will
succeed yeah and once we succeed it does
manna hoop was what effort at what time
and as long as we all succeed that's
what matters
would you would you say that the
property has brought you closer together
as a family
it certainly Alice yeah obviously it has
because we have one of maize reason is
we no matter where they are we've
already arranged the next four months
meetings yeah so they all have to be
there for their meeting regardless and
that gives us a chance to discuss all
the deals all the mathematics that
carries done any problems with admin or
with the bank so if you lava yeah so it
has brought us closer the communication
is a lot better and a lot stronger and
decision-making I think we've just about
nailed that between us
how have you managed because a lot of
parents ask me this
they say Sammy well how can I manage to
fire up my kids and to get my kids
excited about financial freedom and
finance and money and property now some
kids just naturally have a fire to do it
I mean what would you say what would be
your advice to someone who wanted to get
their kids into property how have you
managed to do that I think with any this
might this in my experience with my
children is money I can't call them
children anymore my young adults is I
have to be part I don't I don't not want
to be part of their lives and so to be
part of that I have to do what they want
to do or I can encourage them to do
choose the right path to secure their
futures
yes and that's how it is so if bricks
doing something whether it be football
coaching whether it be DJing whether it
be properly have got involved with all
the carries decision making on the
future we've got a child we've discussed
everything so I I and Jackie are both
part of their upbringing and part of
their decision-making yeah
so by doing that they tend to we've got
a good bond and we listen and that's the
other thing is parents need to listen to
what the kids are saying sometimes you
down you tell or this is how it's got to
be you've got to move this way or you'll
never make it or you'll never be good
but I strongly you know I think that's
wrong and I tend to listen to them and
although I have to tell Ricky shut up
sometimes well yeah I listen to them see
what their thoughts are because what
parents sometimes forget very quickly is
that the lot eight nine ten anymore how
many know mid 20s 30s and they're adults
what's your background and what did you
choose property
well my father used to be in property
and I think I may have told you this
story before but my father was in
property and he had sort of quite a low
prices where we were in Doncaster at the
time and but mama brother hated it
because we was 12 13 14 15 but every and
in those days we didn't have all the
stuff done by agents and the sort of
things we have to do it all yourself
yeah so we spend all summers painting
decorating waiting outside the house for
tennis to show them the house till 9:00
o'clock at night and it kind of just
turned this off property so we left it
for a while and then I remember going
into business and my father I said to my
father what do you think I want to do
this he said the only thing I'll make
you money in this world Rajesh
bricks-and-mortar so don't waste your
time putting money into anything else
money to that and at that time things
turned and my circumstances change so I
forgot it then I remember Kyra coming to
me and saying what do you think you know
come work here all the time so I said
bricks and mortar is what's going to
make you the money so if that's what you
want to do independent put your money
into that and from there that started a
fire in her she started a fire in Rick
and Rick started a fire in all of us
that's fantastic and I mean the fact
that you say the first six months you've
just really spent learning but you've
still and yeah you said it was a small
thing that we've got a couple of ready
to record and we've done a couple of
deal packaged a few deals Ricky's done
but the bottom line is your wife and
your daughter are now financially free
or full-time in property at least yeah
and even rick has more time spare now so
Rick and my wife are totally free and
they they just 100 percent on property
my hell this carry will be the next one
yeah it's incredible single-handedly
every member of your family who come in
financially free what's the big why
what's the what's the what's your
strongest reason for doing this I think
from my point of view is obviously to
make sure that they're independent and
free from work
and they themselves want to be free from
work and I think there's gonna come a
stage and I've already heard Rick and
can you talk about it there's gonna come
a stage where they'd like to do what
you're doing it wants to cut to the
level of success to help other people
and to train other people and they they
want to give something back when they
get to that level it's like a rippling
effect yeah I remember when we first
chatted and we talked about the vision
that when you guys all flying out to
India yeah that's still on financially
free we're on track we are on track
we've got six months to get the other
three or three of us free and we were
actually funny enough you mentioned that
because a couple of days ago we talked
about planning the trip to India well at
the end of October because that's our
end of year from the Academy and we're
hoping to be financially free one two of
you are three more to go in six months
I'd love to get some of your family
members up as well and ask them some
questions so massive congratulations I'm
so pleased to see you guys doing really
well and let's get you'll get your song
on first let's do it
thanks man thanks okay Ricky man you're
awesome bro how old are you I'm 26 26
financially free almost yeah all right
so what do you do with your time now so
every dime I've got like an agenda that
I do every day and I've kind of set my
weeks out I structure my week so I set
as you call it the big day do that every
Wednesday so I'm not gonna put in the
office on a Friday so Wednesday's a big
viewing day first out dude all the
number crunching and you diligence run
over my family Fridays I offered a if
you like putting in the offers ready for
the weekend to you know kind of get them
to come back to me Monday I work with
Alastair on his mental course mental
[ __ ] and packaging and he also helped
remove that on a Monday and then Tuesday
sort of acting and agents again and
going over what I've done for the week
right so this is what this is
life of a full time property investor
yeah right there just summed up yeah
yeah so what I mean you've done what
like a couple rent two essays yeah and
you don't mention them you also doing
deal packaging yeah how many deals have
you sold in the last six weeks last six
weeks we've sold
and we've got a few more that are kind
of going through it the minute both
going but we don't like to just to be
like kind of respectful and we want to
be a credible company we don't we don't
call it done into it so you don't spend
the money until you have the keys yeah
yeah I got yeah yeah but you've got
quite a few in the back yeah that's
great and how much money on average like
the two that you did so how much money
did you get for those it was around
about five grand for both of them
so - nothing yeah we somewhat yeah they
went to the same person because they
went to the same person they bought - we
said we'd negotiated a bit and we done
it five grand for both of them that's
cool what do you think do you see
yourself right now as a lot OMG I'm
pinching myself
isn't it amazing or do you think I've
already done anything actually I'm just
getting started or which is somewhere in
between I'll be honest with you I think
there's so much more that we can do with
this which we know we can do that we've
learnt from the Academy at the minute we
just get inside because there's a lot of
people right now twenty-six-year-old
yeah that would see your life and think
oh my goodness that's the dream like you
do a bit of mentoring on a Monday on a
Tuesday you go and view houses and
yourselves yeah it's like you're making
good money you've just made 5,000 pound
in the last six weeks plus you from your
rent to rents you actually family like
that is the dream for many people yeah I
think it but now it's many people is a
dream and I'm always grateful for having
a supportive family for us kind of being
introduced to the crash course and you
know the program that you guys run with
the Academy I'm always grateful for that
but at the same time I do think there's
so much more to achieving in life you
know we've got all the strategies that
we want to work on our development but
not just with the property and you know
the money side of things it's about
spending time to give her his family and
also being able to give back you know I
heard my dad say earlier which is what
you know definitely I want to get into
is I've created such a good relationship
with you and the stair raxil and and the
Academy guys and it's kind of like a
little family that in the future I
definitely want to educate myself get
experience and then help you guys give
back as well because I believe so much
in it you know I really do yeah
you've seen how we've helped change your
life yeah and people in your family and
you want to pass that on yeah that's
fantastic man so what's been the biggest
what's been the biggest struggles
because you know you started six months
ago you're doing really well but have
there been days when you thought this is
just so hard I want to give up as it
happened a hundred percent okay so I
rang out a spreadsheet when I was
looking for the first rental service
accommodation I had a spreadsheet and
color code it so I do type in the agents
that I'd called and if they said no what
color code it read so I know they've
said no and then I'd do a yellow if they
were like I'll give you a call back if
we have anything and then green was if
they do have some stuff while they do
corporate let's and I've no to make sure
I follow up with them so I had that
spreadsheet I'd put a date I'd ring him
and I just follow up with him every
month if they were yellow or green I
think I rang it was 162 161 agents were
I got the first one yeah you know after
like ten phone calls I'm above the ten
phone calls our second cost there and I
was like I'm just gonna stop and I
thought to myself like remember what you
guys said just keep going for no go for
no and then it was funny because when I
got the first one after 161 call the
second one that we got it came the same
day so he rang one he said look we've
rang an agent he said we've got this
apartment make that happened to do
corporate let's so that was all good
so it raised the view in that look to
the same phone call after the next rung
after the agent said exactly the same he
said to a common view it tonight and
then we viewed it me I remember me my
dad went that day we viewed it we paid
the the you know friend pan they want
before to take it off the market we paid
that and straight after the viewing and
it was like - and just like that so a
hundred and sixty agent said no yeah
before one said yes yeah that is either
you what you was saying on the phone was
awful probably the first but an hour
does learn but that's how you get good
yeah how you get good yeah and you
mentioned that we keep saying go for
know what does go for no moon you just
gotta go I just love no man
someone tells me that I'm like this is
great because I'm just that much closer
to it yes yeah you know is that most
people they'll make two or three phone
calls they'll get told no and then
they'll say it doesn't work yeah if you
just said Samuel
I've rang a hundred people I've rung a
hundred and fifty nine people and
they've all said no it would have been
logical to say it doesn't work but your
persistence carries your throat and
you're not funny that agent that was a
hundred CC first phone call he sends me
apartments that he knows I'm looking for
corporate let's and that well you know
allow it in the head lease and stuff
like that allows it so now every week he
sends me at least two in that same block
that can do it and he's just send them
to me and we're gonna take one some more
probably but obviously we're looking
onto other stuff now but him just send
them to me um he knows as well I can
pass them on so I stopped a win-win for
everyone
so I'm parks in Amman and we take them
on ourselves good relationship with an
agent is better than a good deal yeah
first deal is always your hardest deal
yeah and not only because like you said
the agents now asking you lots more Sam
Avenue so many think Sam of an investor
the first time you sell a deal to an
investor it's hard yeah but then what
you just said your investor bought -
yeah and I bet he'll buy another one
next month and then one next month
probably as long as you continue
delivering which you well your first is
always your hardest not only because
you're not very good because when you
start you're not very good and you have
to practice yeah but also I bet some of
those 159 agents that said no I bet it
won't know about it I bet some of them
it was not for now oh yeah and now
they're calling you back probably I'd
certainly top of them work well it's a
no for now we haven't got anything yeah
at the minute but ya know they snow is
still email me stuff and it's just it
sounds weird but sometimes it's hard to
kind of keep up with when agents are
just sending these stuff through that
you know I spoke to this agent like six
months ago and they're sending me stuff
through now that you know I'm looking at
I'm like when you know how to sort some
package deals this is like a gift you
take that and pass it on and just you
know I work with everyone build the good
relationships and everyone's gonna win
from it and I say I know
we teach don't count it assault it's
completely gone through everything
mother yeah but on average how many per
week per month deals are you selling or
agreeing with investors like house like
yeah so I'm aiming for at least one a
week yeah and so on so at the minute I'm
slowly building my investors list
because deal source is not something
that I want to do kind of full-time but
I'm slowly building up my list might aim
to put out there and speak to people
investor wise and sell for a month yeah
that's what I mainly before if you're
doing to north granny traver egde that's
ten thousand pound a month yeah just on
passing property deals yeah you don't
want yourself yeah and he said well if
you do a big day and you look no less
than ten viewings in a day when I'm
gonna do that big down on Wednesday no
less than ten viewings out of that ten
at least one we'll put an offering on at
least one yeah you know normally it's
two or three and then I'll go back we'll
all run the figures and then offer on or
you'll have an offer except you don't
want no we're puttin up well I put I'll
put offers on and probably about five or
six yeah and then at an in five or six
offers better get get accepted about one
around two or three yeah yeah slightly
on a bad week it's just one will accept
it alright so what's been the biggest
thing you've learned over the last six
months of becoming financially free the
biggest thing I've learned is definitely
to make the most out of your time now so
you can you know reap the rewards in the
future hmm
and it's not just you know money or you
know being able to buy stuff it's just
because we're doing as a family spending
time as a family
like you can't put a price on that yeah
and you can't really do that if you you
know work a busy job that you have to go
to every day what's the end goal the end
goal is to be able to have a massive
being a business property portfolio and
that will just you know going out for
generations and generations and we leave
a legacy not just at a property but you
know teaching you know helping with you
know the Academy and stuff you know help
them not help with your back because you
obviously but you don't need help but
you know what about to give back to you
for giving us an opportunity to be
involved with
that and your money or you'll leave a
legacy with your money but more than
anything who you are will be a legacy
yeah who you are because I think you're
an incredible person don't you know your
heart and your action yeah I would say
if you learn and then implement with the
right belief you cannot fail
yeah and that's you know your example of
that you know you've got the skills and
you've just absolutely gone for it
despite the rejection you've gone for it
you've had belief and and you've
succeeded which is just absolutely
fantastic all right top top tip then for
someone who is wanting to become
financially free in their 20s just
starting out just take the bungee jump
and just don't even think about it just
go for whatever you want to go for 100%
get the right education first because
otherwise education if we didn't have
the education then you know where we've
been or there's no there's nothing more
dangerous than an uneducated idiot yeah
especially if they're an action taker
yeah if you're an idiot who doesn't take
action then nothing will happen yeah and
if you're an idiot
and you're educated and you take action
then you could potentially cause all
kinds of problems
yeah so it's good that you got educated
say educate yourself and as you say do
the bungee jump yeah but I just
just take the jump with the right
knowledge and you know the help that you
can get you're gonna be successful from
it you might not dance but you're gonna
be successful if you want it bad enough
yeah but you have to know what you're
doing otherwise you you you could end up
in trouble yeah and you know no one
worth especially with things on a
serviced accommodation of rent to rents
you don't understand the rules it's
funny you say that actually we like what
as soon as we started the Academy and we
we did we ever had the rental I say
there yet we actually got a service
accommodation and rental assay but
because we haven't been on a rental say
hey everyone we haven't got any
experience in it or anything we just
took it because we spoke to a few people
about it and it's funny to say that
because that rents were saying now we
just pulled out a contract a few weeks
ago because now we've had the day in the
Train and we know what we're looking for
and that's not that's something that was
gonna lose us money so we managed to put
out of it but we realize now you
that's that was gonna cost us I think it
was 1,200 a month and for the rent about
it wasn't gonna work but we you know we
did it before into the training day and
it's an example being edgy did you
follow me or did you buy it from a deal
sorcerer no I found that one but the
worrying thing is there's a lot of deal
packages out there to find bad rent to
essays that don't work and then try and
flog them you're uneducated people yeah
yeah yeah it's scary it's scary because
even I think a lot of times that people
think if you're buying a house and
obviously that's a lot more risky and
scarier than if you're renting because
rents not as much money but when you
think about it that one that you know we
just pulled out was gonna be 1,200 a
month and if you're not feeling it you
know that's your stuff that's a lot of
money that we lose in every single month
yeah so I think you know if you're
looking to games probably full-stop know
what you're looking for if you're gonna
barf a saucer that's fine what the top
three things you look for in a good
renter is a property a good rental I say
property two top three things I look for
number one is location you know you want
to be town center city center walking
distance to public transport and the
other thing is condition you want to
make sure the conditions like the tops
wet because it's not it's not only your
property so you don't want to be pumping
money into it because it's not you asset
yeah and so you want to be a good
standard top-spec and the last thing is
you have to make sure it's you know
compliant and equal to do with that
particularly especially apartments you
make sure the head lease is fine make
sure the landlord's ok with it and make
sure and their mortgage and stuff and
out short net long as you've got them
free the location and the condition of
it is on a zero point it will work I
love that fantastic
so what's gonna be the next big thing
for you guys
we've already got a few stuff in you
know in the line already that we're
looking at and the next big thing I
think what we're looking at Barberie for
every finance and development yeah so at
the minute we've got the advantage of
because we're doing as a family we've
got kind of someone's looking like this
some of them at that and what we're
doing is we're just putting out the bad
ones and I'm sure we're gonna come to a
good deal I've got a feeling it's gonna
be a bi reef every finance purse yeah
and then from that we're going to go
into a development love them we just
wanna you know he's slowly going bigger
and bigger
and big technologies it's just it's
using the tools in the toolbox that
would learn you know we've went to
assays we're doing sourcing we're doing
by refurb refinance we're going to do
developments we're doing this is all the
tools that we've we've acquired from you
know being on a 12-month program
what's the Academy like so it's like the
best thing that we've ever done as a
family because you'd get stung a feeding
down on it you have to know what you're
doing but the biggest thing for me me
personally is it's the people as well
like the relationships I've got with all
the people and the Academy is just it's
crazy like I never ever thought I'd be
in this position and yeah the knowledge
you get is priceless you can't put a
price on it it's so valuable you know
and it's always unexpected things as
well
so when we slide we thought you know
it's gonna be a great 12 months when
they learn everything about property
from Samuel 1 and the team and stuff
then let the trainer's just like I don't
know where you bought someone in you
know it will get a guest as a surprise
and it's like you say you know you under
promise and over deliver all the time
it's like constantly though yeah you
know it's brilliant we love it I love
that man listen I'm so proud of you I'm
gonna quickly grab your mom and your
sister to come and share a few words as
well but dude keep doing what you're
doing
any time give me a shout respect cool
man thanks very much well Cheers
Carrie yeah the star of the show I like
to fix is so what's your role within the
family business so I do the numbers so
my background is I was the sensible
child sorry okay but I did well at
school I went to you needed maths got a
master's degree in maths and got into a
good job to be fair earned quite a lot
for my age and to qualify to my job I
have to do exams yeah I know I have to
about 15 of them and I got down to the
final two and exams are two left and I
know I just got to a point where I just
thought this is this is it you know I
mean once I've done these two exams I
see it so I wanted to do something else
and property just seemed to make sense
because it involves the numbers and
stuff and dad like does always said his
background he's always wanted skiing to
prop a and so I do the numbers basically
what does that mean
the numbers but am i right in thinking
that you were kind of the Warren Cary
who lit the fire in the whole family
yeah cuz you wanted to get into property
yeah what what why did you enter
property wink is like I said I got to
that point in my job where I'd kind of
made it to what to be what we do and
swabber no pensions actuary okay very
like numbers easy yeah and I got to the
point where I was I'd almost kind of
done what I wanted to do and not just
for I'll need something else yeah
I'm satisfied in you job I don't think
so I mean one thing that I thought is
where do I want to be and who do I want
to be in what 20 years time and I am I
gonna be that person doing what I'm
doing right now yes and I decided I
wasn't going to be so I wanted to free
myself up so that I could do other
things and I think a key trigger for art
as I don't think it's been mentioned yet
is a bummer was actually ill a couple of
years ago she had heart surgery and I
think a key thing that kind of triggered
me and my head is we were all trying to
take time off and kind of struggle to be
there for mum which he's fine now by the
way and and I think I just thought now I
was it's not right I don't I just want
to be able to be there with her all the
time and I think we all thought that and
it was kind of that struggle between us
just to find some time for her that kind
of made me think I can't I don't want
that for the rest of my life I want some
time and what's freedom to do what I
want to do it's powerful yeah and
sometimes it takes seriously bad things
to happen
yeah like I found in her almost dying or
yes made drastic yeah yeah actually wake
up yeah you're sat there at work and
mums lying in hospital and I'm just
thinking no it's not it's not what I
think you realize actually life is short
yeah and and the conventional plan for
life which is to have a job work till
you're 67 retire on 40% of what you
couldn't afford to live on in the first
place yeah it just sucks yeah so how's
life different now and we were not
closer as a family and I'm actually
happier to work so I'm still working
full-time yeah but I think because I
have this on the side as well and I know
where we're going I actually feel
happier to go to work yeah because it's
not it's more of an option you know if I
went
because we're kind of making passive
income if I went home and said you know
I want to work part-time now it would be
okay yeah because I have that option I'm
okay not to do that yeah I think yes I
really agree what you sound like when
you're working from a position of
abundance yeah from a position of choice
it's so much different for ya when you
have to go because then you're like
almost like a slave yeah but I work hard
yeah on my business ya know my train
people and I've and like buying
properties and I'm I work hard but
because because it's completely optional
on your own it feels great
yeah cuz if I want to take a holiday for
a month or two I can yeah that's really
interesting so in regards to numbers
then how important is being able to work
out things like the return on investment
and crunch the numbers how important is
that it is it's everything so we've had
we look between the five of us we find
loads of deals every week and I've I
will kind of create a spreadsheet and
over in different options you can put in
with different options worst-case
scenarios yeah and I'm just basically
formulated so you can press a button say
we're gonna buy a house with me fair bit
you press a button and it tells you what
is that like highest possible offer you
can put in to make X amount and you
might you just created this bread shape
yes I think how do you even know how to
figure it all out cuz I just work off in
spreadsheets every day I just know that
you know it's scary though how many
people could call themselves and I say
this at the property investors crash
course how many people call themselves
property professionals or professional
investors and they don't even know how
to work out something as basic as the
return on investment yeah it is really
important and I mean there's we I did
use a starting point some of the Academy
spreadsheets actually that we got why
did you - yeah because it's funny
because sometimes people will say the
property business is a people business
and then other people say no actually
the property business is a numbers game
and I think it's that it is everything
is everything yeah and that's what you
know in my training I'll start very
basic this is the basic ROI sheet that
you need this is your formulas these are
the basic people skills here's the
scripts but some people will flourish in
one area and like itself you've made
you've made the spreadsheets now look
like primary school spreadsheet
the really complicated yeah thoughts I
think yeah the spreadsheets also I think
something you said before is not to use
me feet go with your feelings to go to
the formulas and I think just having
everything on a spreadsheet like one of
these guys like Rick will brick it say
oh look at this deal and it would be
like a really nice house in a nice area
and we can do a refurb and make it even
better but once she sees it on a
spreadsheet it's the reality the numbers
it kind of just emphasizes that so I
think it is really important do you
think that it's easy when you don't know
the formulas and you don't have the
spreadsheets to just by totally based on
your heart and feelings yeah yes I see I
have a long time he'll buy at the fall
in love with the property yeah and and
if they have someone like you in their
team they just I'm sure you wouldn't let
them buy something that they just loved
because it's gotta be a numbers game
okay so what would you say your kind of
vision for the future is then what's
your kind of source of plan what you
most excited about right now I do want
to stop work and eventually just so that
I can have my time to myself when like
women that way well I've just taken my
last exam yeah and that was kind of in
my head something that I just wanted to
do because it's what I've been working
towards for the last 10 or so years so I
just want to get that done I'm just
taking now and I don't know if I passed
yet okay I'll find out in July and then
if I have then I guess after that so but
this year you think it will be a year
hopefully yeah yeah and then yeah and
then dad wanted to well we have the
India trip which we've already touched
on and I think more longer-term and dad
wanted to go back to India we put an
idea out and kind of build schools there
and stuff from where he was from and
that's something we've been there a
couple of times and that is something
that I would definitely love to do it
kind of in the longer term yeah and the
longer longer town just like you do you
know give give back and help people
change their lives that's a long time
you guys have such big hearts so what
will be your number one piece of advice
to someone who was wanting to do what
following your footsteps as a property
entrepreneur I think you can learn so
much from putting yourself out there and
meeting people which is something I
was never as good at ricks obviously
puts himself out there and I've just
seen from him how much he gets from
people just from kind of putting himself
out there and speaking out a little bit
about what he's doing yeah and I think
that is really important you tell people
what you want to do and the right people
will come to you so you cook you out so
I think that's a key point you know what
there's a lot of people that are like
secret property investors yeah and then
they try and do it quietly and then when
they become financially free they're
like Tara yeah but actually I really
agree with what you just said you've got
to speak it out and put it out there
many I believe that when you say look
guys family tell if when you tell the
world what you're about to do people
will just get out of your way yeah
really love that yeah thanks so much
okay so you are the admin person and the
mom of the family so how's the journey
being for you so far yeah fantastic as
has already been said I've retired from
work yeah which is fantastic so now I've
got the time to be the foundation I
think you know mums are the foundation
of the family absolutely doing all the
stuff that's what I'm doing for the
business I mean there must be so I mean
I know you're an inspiration to your
family
I mean becoming financially free and
quitting work but you must be so proud
of your kids they're just fun tightly
you know I mean where do you think they
get that fire from dad yeah yeah
so that what's your role then within the
proper within the family business the
property company right so I as I say I'm
kind of the the underpin so I do all the
filing I found out what they people what
they need when they go out to something
I get all their emails and drag them
into folders so when they look at their
phones they're looking at a property
then go to the phones go to a particular
folder all the information for that one
property is in in that folder yes
so I got from Ricky the others go to
work so they're trying to do that
alongside that same message everybody
especially keep it simple for you really
it's so important
it's quite self-contained out to be fair
but he's got the time to be nurse yeah
yeah so what would you say your kind of
strongest reason why is why are you
doing this it's just so good to see the
kids and you in what they yeah what
they're doing you know I'm looking
forward to the future I can't say that
for all of those would you think I don't
know
miss Irene our bellies again what have
you learned in this whole property
process over the last six months
oh gosh so much so much you can do it as
a family
yeah I wouldn't have thought in a
million years as a family it would work
but we've all we haven't had to sit down
and say right what do you want to do
what do you weave naturally fallen into
our own roles and there's no wheatley
within your family like normally no
normally there'll be someone who's
really passionate and the leader and
then there'll be people that are just
dead wood where I find with the Mandel
family with you guys you're also driven
and you're also conscientious and and
hard-working
you've got completely different skill
set however is it too
for a family to do are you just have
really unique set of family members
where if somehow works or do you think
that it is very viable know to come
together as a family definitely all
families every child is different we all
say that parents don't work every child
is different and I think we all are
different founders anyone can find their
own swapped and how do you structure the
company like are you all directors or
how have you don't have you done that we
started out Raj and I were the directors
yeah and we're all and the kids are
shareholders and I think I think that's
in the middle of a change now I think
we're all gonna be directors aren't we
and you have you have like minutes to
the board meeting we do I do the agenda
I do the minutes of the last meeting and
the agenda for the next one you got to
take it serious though absolutely it
makes us all sit down around the table
not your armchairs with a cup of tea or
anything yes sit around the table pretty
much like this one and yeah that's what
we do so inspired and it's very rare
that that I have such you know if I'm so
inspired by it by a family business like
this what advice would you give to
someone who was wanting to do this as a
family business what are the key things
to look out for as everybody said the
training is crucial and if everybody can
go to the training we are one missing
I've just been to to one of the crash
courses really inspired her so she knows
where we're coming from but the training
we can all follow what you've said and
the times that we've said Samuel was
right he was dead right
you know sometimes we weave beard I can
think of an odd odd thing or two where
we veered and thought no yeah I think
he's just like a road map isn't it when
you when you have good training it's
almost like you have you've got a guide
so that rather than your own ideas about
the other it's like well this is the
road map this is where we're going yeah
and of course it's Facebook
yeah go on there yeah you know the times
I spoken to Rick kisaki forgetting about
it and he says gone the Academy Facebook
it can be on there
I remember seeing somebody somebody
asking about it and somebody had replied
sometimes it's you yourself replied and
it's all that it is and it is well I'm
so impressed and I'm so pleased to know
you guys as friends so massive congrats
what's next then what's to be gained for
you this year what are you most excited
about q um I'm excited I'm excited for
whatever comes along either a re I've
got in my heart I feel it might be one
of the refurbs but there's a nice piece
of land we've seen as well I don't know
all of it Samuel all that well any help
you need give me a shout any time I
can't Congrats on your success so far
thank you people ask me why I've run the
property investors Academy and do the
crash courses and one of the reason is
because I really like making friends and
I think this has really been a testimony
to that for fabulous family members I
hope you've been inspired by that if
you're wanting to go into property and
don't forget get the training coming
down to the property investors crash
course and bring your families because
there's nothing more rewarding and
fruitful and fun than building a
business
with your family and becoming
financially free together thank you so
much for watching I'll see you next time